and what is the true so that's you know  that's I would say like okay words  language right our divine nature like  soul and what is that can you prove it  right the Atheist materialist will have  a heart problem with this so the divine  nature the soul that's the true self and  then the ego is not the true self yeah  it's like you know the just I have  sometimes problem people destroy your  ego the ego is bad it's not like that  it's more like fine-tuning or D  conditioning yourself which is intense  process to the disillusionment and all  this stuff comes out we need to heal and  bring the soul the psyche being a shrew  you've been asset to the front like neh  Eric teaching talks about the necessity  to like Girja talks about to grow the  soul that we don't know how to have  actually true access to it and then add  understanding all right and then the ego  person becomes a pure expression of that  because we still did we all have